people are really up in arms right now
about this blindfold giveaway prank this
YouTuber went into a Target and found
this man and his son and told them if
they blindfolded themselves and fit as
many toys or items into their cart as
they could in one minute then he would
buy them everything in the cart halfway
through the guy and his friend just walk
away so is this a big deal do I think
this was a good prank no I don't think
it was a good prank the problem is here
is that there's no payoff so while the
idea of it might be kind of funny they
just walk away it would be like watching
The Blair Witch Project and never
getting to the part with the house I
think a really good prank has also one
that fools the subject but also Delights
them when they find out that it's a
prank now do I think this is a huge deal
do I think this is the end of the world
not really I mean someone's gonna have
to clean all that up most likely the man
and his son which is kind of crappy but
at the end of the day like nobody got
hurt a lot of people are upset because I
guess the kid had a hearing aid always
wanted to be on a Mr abuse prank or
something it's not like he's going to be
more disappointed because he has the
hearing aid and I'm not saying any of
that to excuse the pranksters again I
don't think that the content was good
but let me know your thoughts on this